ich weiß natürlich nicht wie es ihnen
geht aber ich zittere immer noch vor
erregung im politischen berlin ist etwas
ja wie erklärt man das regelrecht
passiert angela merkel hört als cdu
chefin auf plötzlich tut sich was in der
union nach 18 jahren wachkoma man könnte
auch sagen die cdu
sie lebt meine damen und herren
es ist doch schön ich find's super und
die merkel macht ja erstmal weiter als
kanzlerin
wer weiß vielleicht sogar noch für
mehrere wochen kann ja sein ja trotzdem
ist das natürlich schon zäsur was wir da
erleben das ist kein grund zum
trübsalblasen macht ja auch keiner in
weiten teilen der union heißt es eher
hoch die hände merkel ende ja das ist so
so und jetzt fragen sich natürlich die
expertin geht das überhaupt
kanzlerschaft und cdu-vorsitz trennen
sie erinnern sich als kanzler schröder
damals den spd parteivorsitz abgeben
musste da hat ja ein junger zonen
backfisch völlig zu recht gefragt wie
kann man ein land wie die bundesrepublik
deutschland führen wenn man die eigene
partei die eigenen mitglieder in der
sozialdemokratischen partei nicht führen
kann wie kann man gute frage
das ist das blöde heutzutage jeder
scheiß den man irgendwann mal gelabert
hat wird aufbewahrt
von der lügen presse
großes wagen ist wirklich ein großes
wagnis nur als kanzlerin weiter machen
so was ändert wenn es blöd läuft
ratzfatz in der frührente dann heißt es
lautes heim glück allein ja schön in der
uckermark mit professor sauer
sie behauptet ja sie hätte das alles
schon im letzten sommer so entschieden
kann ja sein aber klar was den letzten
ausschlag gegeben hat da können wir nur
spekulieren vielleicht ist hier in der
küche das kaffeepulver runtergefallen
und hat auf dem boden botschaft
hinterlassen oder sie hat ihren papagei
gefüttert ist natürlich alles quatsch in
wirklichkeit stand es in einem
glückskeks bogen sie mal hier verkünde
am 29 oktober dass du den parteivorsitz
aufgibt und auf der rückseite stand
deine partei hast dich ja wirklich stand
alles so in dem keks den hatte ich auch
mal so aber
aber wer weiß vielleicht hört frau
merkel ja gar nicht freiwillig auf die
bild behauptet zumindest es gebe da fünf
prominente cdu verschwörer die sie sonst
weggeputzt städten
der oettinger wird genannt der strobl
und über die anderen drei kann man
wirklich nur spekulieren das könnte
das könnte jeder sein
die sammer dazu raten das wäre unseriös
meine meinung und wie schön dass man uns
bürgern monate lang erzählt wir wollen
zur sacharbeit zurück zur sacharbeit und
jetzt dreht sich wieder alles nur um
köpfe und thronfolge fragen jens spahn
bewirbt sich zum beispiel um den
parteivorsitz wissen sie
der blutjunge merkel kritiker das wäre
quasi so merkel of life jens sparen der
weiter zwanghaften afd themen hinterher
ich und auch in dieser woche annegret
kramp karrenbauer tritt an muttis beste
und überraschungsgast friedrich merz
einer prominenter als der andere die
fehler sind begeistert können sie mir
sagen wer diese drei personen sind ja
kramp karrenbauer und und wissen sie den
weg für 3 personen würden sie es mit
einer voran
so
das geht sie gar nichts an wer als
erster alle drei genannten bewerber
punkten in der cdu natürlich vor allem
mit einer wichtigen eigenschaft sie sind
nicht angela merkel
das scheint im moment bedeutet sie seien
aber am spannendsten
da werden sie mir zustimmen ist
natürlich schon diese personalie
friedrich merz damals von merkel
persönlich rausgemobbt kehrt fritze
zurück und bringt frischen wind in die
cdu mit seinen 62 jahren
kann das gut gehen kann das gutgehen
parteichef märz und kanzlerin merkel bis
2021 das folgende klingt jedenfalls ein
bisschen wie eine drohung
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
angela merkel und ich miteinander unter
diesen veränderten bedingungen auskommen
und klar kommen werden und zwar so wie
wir beide es dann gemeinsam beurteilen
ach komm ich und die merkel wir werden
super klar kommen muss ich sie
rausschmeißen
einen tag vor heiligabend dann hat die
lg für immer fritze frei ja friedrich
merz steht für die alte cdu das wissen
sie für die alte cdu hat noch eine
jungpartei war bevor die alle merkel den
laden komplett kastriert hat jetzt kommt
die rache der penisse freunde natürlich
ja
man hat es ja versucht mit der frau ist
hat mich funktioniert die cdu soll
endlich wieder für sicherheit stehen für
ordnung für heimat mama papa
heterosexuelle kinder und natürlich ganz
wichtig für wirtschaftsnähe kurz gesagt
mit kanzler märz kriegen wir die
sozialste politik die in deutschland
jemals gemacht hat
gottseidank beide damen und herren ja
nicht umsonst haben sich sämtliche
deutschen wirtschaftsverbände diese
woche wegen märz vorfreude eingenässt ja
deutsche aufsichtsratchef bei blackrock
dem größten vermögensverwalter der welt
aber nicht nur da der typ sitzt in mehr
aufsichtsräten als es überhaupt firmen
gibt es wahnsinn
im dezember entscheidet sich die merkel
nachfolge bei einem parteitag das
passende handy spiel haben wir schon
heute die spucke motto hol dir jetzt
merkel nachfolge motto lauf durchs
berliner regierungsviertel und suche
alle möchtegern merkel erben an jeder
ecke lauert einer rum ag
das ehrgeizige sparen der mögliche
hobbit laschet und natürlich fritzl der
blackrock millionär mit der goldenen
glatze sammeln sie alle und lasse sie in
sinnlosen kämpfen gegen
dann treten merkel nachfolge mondo was
für eine zeitverschwendung und für
fortgeschrittene so simon go finde
irgend einen doofen der freiwillig den
job von andrea nahles macht keine chance
euro
jetzt nicht im heute-show app store frau
merkels entscheidung hat natürlich weit
reichende konsequenzen und zwar nicht
nur für die cdu selbst nein
millionen von deutschen bricht demnächst
das feindbild weg an die denkt keiner
immer mehr besorgte bürger sind total
besorgt denn angela merkel hört bald auf
diese egoistische entscheidung der
kanzlerin raubt vielen den lebenssinn
menschen die dennis knossalla ihren
apathisch durch unsere städte und wissen
nicht mehr weiter
ich habe jahrelang gebetet dass die alle
aufhört aber jetzt wo es so weit ist da
fühle ich mich so näher
vor allem müssen wir jetzt völlig neue
texte einüben vielen dank auch merkel
ist ja auch horst j diesmal zeitung ihre
alten demo schilder können sie
wegschmeißen und müssen jetzt für jeden
möglichen merkel nachfolger neue malen
und ruft die scheiße auf das gerät kann
kann eine gesamte er brauchen kann er
sich recht haben bauermann kann was ich
tue wahnsinnig gut weil der name kurz
ist und der ist auch gegen islam und so
aber der kann natürlich nicht cdu-chef
werden weil ja der ist ja aus dem
münsterland ich hasse das münsterland
die lücke die angela merkel hinterlässt
kann auch das privatleben des besorgten
bürgers nicht füllen
ich versuche jetzt stand merkel meine
frau scheiße zu finden
ach das ist nicht das ende
wenn es für beide können uns doch ab
jetzt mehr unterhalten
schauen sie nicht mehr machen sie mit
bei unserer aktion
merkel muss bleiben damit sie weg muss
[Musik]